[Музика]
знає, що мої фішки складні, але не з
рішенням для майстерності, особливо якщо ви не
закінчите те, що є Dodge. Перестановка — це
погане лайно Хаммонд і Іст Мауї тепер
про très malade, вона не контролює
більше, ніж це число  як справи з дитиною
[Музика]
привіт, хлопці, пора уроку англійської,
мене звати Ентоні давайте почнемо
і мої дорогі гості знову так привіт, Джена,
як ти добре добре,
Х'ю Аліна привіт чудово, фантастично давайте
почнемо урок сьогодні ми збираємося
кінотеатр погоджуюсь добре, фантастично,
давайте, це буде віртуальний
кінотеатр для старших без проблем, тож давайте перевіримо
домашнє завдання, яке ви пам'ятаєте, я попросив вас
написати речення, моя улюблена телепрограма «
Я не можу терпіти», означає, що я
ненавиджу або не люблю  ніби я вважаю щось
смішне або цікаве в нудному, ти можеш
сказати, а я ніколи не дивлюся, тому ми починаємо з
Олени, чи не могли б ви розповісти мені свої
речення, мої улюблені телепрограми так
вгору, шоу мильні опери, мильні опери, я
не витримав жахів, які я знайшов  візок  oons
смішно добре я ніколи не дивлюся жахи мм-хм,
вони нудні так добре Соня, давайте підемо
з тобою моя улюблена телепрограма добре
комедійне шоу добре так так я терпіти не можу
мильні опери добре я вважаю, що мультфільм смішний,
я ніколи не дивлюся, впевнений, що я  ніколи не дивлюся
я ніколи не дивлюся мильні опери це нудно
добре молодець
ладно давайте переглянемо
прикметники що перший був
цікавим
не дивно відрізняється наступний
сказав так і пригнічує наступний
смішно добре і тепер підходить дивовижно і
точно захоплююче  Суспільство точно це
правильно молоде так нудно так нудно
і останнє Гарі так нет гей
страшно або страшно їздити так
страшно страшно добре так давайте
скажемо це слово ще раз страшно
страшно чи можна сказати як поліцейський
лякаючий поліцейський наляканий так страшно,
так це страшно  п'ятниця
оллайн страшно страшно добре
скажімо як принцеса страшно
страшно так що це знову
страшно правильно драма добре тепер давайте
пограємо в га  Мені це буде гра у вгадування
ми подивимося хто швидше Соня чи
Олена добре я покажу тобі, ти
дивишся на мене я покажу тобі емоції, які ти
вгадуєш, але ми побачимо, хто швидше, тому тобі
потрібно пояснити  тобі потрібно сказати: О, дитинко,
добре, так смішно.
Браво Дженні була швидше, вибачте, одна точка
до Дженні, я добре,
гм, Керрі, добре, моя мама.
добре три два і ще один
для Аліни нудний
тато так депресивно це три три,
і це означає, що є нічия нічия нічия
Дрю батарея Махало Дрю BA нічия або
ми можемо сказати, що гравітон з краваткою є
нічия або краватка yessiree ніхто не хоче добре
давайте  продовжуй, зараз це просять мої
студенти, тому дайте слово, а ви допоможіть
мені правильно відповісти подивіться на
слова, букви змішані, що це
смішно смішно так виправте наступне слово
цікаво захоплююче захоплююче Браво
Соня наступне нудно добре і
останній так, твій улюблений а  і знову один
два три правильно добре,
зараз ми йдемо в
кіно, щоб пообідати в кінотеатрі глядачів, і
давайте подивимося, що відбувається, тому
перший пан.  Пінгвіни Поппера:
це життя бізнесмена, яке змінилося,
коли він отримав у спадок шість пінгвінів, що це
за фільм, що це за тип
фільму, що це за фільм, комедія так,
це комедія, цей був цей, тому
ковбої та інопланетяни
а  космічний корабель прибуває в Арізону,
що це за фентезі чи пригодницька
фантастика, пам'ятати, що це все,
тому що це про космос, пам'ятайте, що у нас
був опис, тому фільми про майбутнє
чи космос наступний Хоббіт,
що це за фентезі або пригодницька
пригода, обидва можливі пригодницькі
фентезі Шерлок Холмс
детектив хороший  екшн, тому що там
відбувається багато речей, що і
останній втік з планети Земля
природа або комедія чи анімація так,
це як мультфільм, який
ви б хотіли подивитися,
виявляє прихильність тінь замок, певна, алена
для вас Хоббіт Хоббіт, але  нам
потрібно вирішити, що ми можемо дивитися лише один
фільм, ми раді, давайте, і яка робота
вам подобається не дуже багато ви
пам'ятаєте фрази  e з наших попередніх
уроків я не проти, я не проти, так
, все добре, я не проти
послухай, на який фільм вони погоджуються добре
добре який з них ми будемо дивитися, щоб
ти послухав тут, Кіт, щоб ти відчував, що я
буду шукати, щоб підтримувати зв'язок добре
слухай добре готовий
добре привіт Білл, ти хочеш піти в
кіно завтра ввечері добре  чому б не
те, що відбувається, особисто я люблю
науково-фантастичні фільми, тому я хотів би побачити
догори ногами, що ви думаєте, вибачте, Алане,
але, чесно кажучи, я терпіти не можу науково-фантастичних
фільмів, я віддаю перевагу комедії, ну, є
один, який називається  Містер.  Пінгвіни Поппера, хм,
я не чув про нього, що
про бізнесмена, чиє життя змінилося,
коли він успадкував шість пінгвінів, хто це
в ньому, головні ролі: Джим Керрі ах він мені дуже сподобався,
я думаю, що цей фільм починається о сьомій,
тож давайте познайомимось  за межами кінотеатру о
6:30 добре користувач, так які з них я
буду дивитися Mr.  Король Mr.  правильні пінгвіни
так, Mr.  правильні пінгвіни, тож давайте обговоримо
цей діалог, добре в Саранзі,
у нас є прогалини, подивіться
один два три чотири правильно, і ми повинні
заповнити правильне слово номер один привіт,
Білл, ти хочеш піти назад
чи хочеш перейти до  кінотеатр йде
чому, тому що після like after fancy ми
використовуємо форму ing я люблю ходити я хочу йти
так ing форма дозвольте мені написати це для вас
добре добре скажи мені подобається або як це також
можливо йти ми маємо цю форму
добре
я хочу піти я  як ідуть, будь ласка,
пам'ятайте це, давайте перейдемо до номеру два
, подивіться на середину, це
про бізнесмена, який хто є хто, хто є
хто великий, хто є так, хто бачить
так, чиє життя змінюється добре, чи
можемо ми сказати, який який, якщо ми маємо  подивившись
на те саме речення, йдеться про
бізнесмена, який змінює життя, чи можемо ми сказати
це, яке життя ні не тільки чиє
яке стосується речей, підготовлених людиною, ми використовуємо
яку з ярликами, ми використовуємо тільки чий, тільки
добре, добре, давайте перейдемо до номера три
внизу.  - Ха,
мені подобається  він це він, гей, так правильно,
він мені дуже подобається, і останній чудовий,
я думаю, що фільм починається о сьомій, тому
давайте зустрінемося вгору, вниз, так, давай зустрінемося
добре, зустрінемось, так, це правильний
діалект для вас і я  я хочу, щоб ти прочитав
добре,
тому хто буде Алан, кому
буде виставлено рахунок Алан Алан дитина і Білл Аллен
добре, почніть, будь ласка, привіт Білл,
ти хочеш піти в кіно
завтра ввечері,
добре, чому
який син, добре, я особисто мені подобається
науково-фантастичних фільмів, тому я хотів би побачити
догори ногами, що ви думаєте, вибачте, Алане,
але, чесно кажучи, я терпіти не можу 5
фільмів,
я віддаю перевагу комедіям, а є один на
ім'я Mr.  Пінгвіни Купера Поппера
[Сміх]
про бізнесмена,
який пішов у відпустку, життя змінилося, коли він
тут, на Криті, успадкував шість
пінгвінів
Джеррі, хто в ньому знявся Джим Керрі,
о, він мені дуже подобається,
я думаю, що цей фільм починається о  сім,
тож давайте зустрінемося о 6:30 поза кінотеатром,
добре, побачимося там так,
дуже дякую, рег. о, добре, але у мене є
запитання до вас, що це таке, це наукова
фантастика так, як ми читаємо цього
науково-фантастичного ботаника  '
sky 5 щось гаразд Skyfall це
зовсім інша річ так, саме ми
обговорювали це на попередньому уроці
так, ми говорили про Джеймса Бонда пам'ятайте,
але сьогодні це наукова фантастика, добре, давайте
рухаємося далі, тому ми зосередимося на
виразах, все добре, ні  хвилює, як
висловити Мені подобається, щоб ми знали, що мені подобається, що
ще ми можемо сказати замість цієї фрази,
якщо ти збираєшся весь час повторювати Мені
подобається Мені подобається, Мені подобається, це нудно, нам
потрібно показати, що нам потрібно багато, ми багато знаємо
слів у нас багатий словниковий запас, тому
ле  t замініть цими словами давайте змінимо
ви також знаєте тепер фантазії
фантазії я хочу йти Мені подобається дивитися Мені
подобається дивитися
інші речі і лід дивитися,
висловлюючи оцінки "подобається" добре, мені дуже подобається, це
означає "лайк" набагато більше мені подобається
це також можливо  добре, давайте
візьмемо фразу, оскільки ми говоримо про
телешоу, оскільки ми говоримо про
телешоу, почнемо з фрази я люблю
дивитися комедії добре,
я люблю дивитися моменти, давайте замінимо
я хочу дивитися комедії, повторюйте,
будь ласка, я хочу дивитися  комедії
та Лена, давайте йти з Мені дуже подобається,
я дуже люблю дивитися комедію,
Дженні, я можу піти з Мені подобається мені
подобається добре висловлювати те, що
мені не подобається, тому ми говоримо, що мені не подобається те,
що я ненавиджу  ненавиджу пам'ятати з
попереднього уроку я терпіти не можу я не можу
залишитися я не можу терпіти так або я просто ненавиджу
це також можливо о я вважаю
щось нудним або складним, а ви
пояснюєте страшне, страшне і так далі
і веселощі  це  означає, що вам це
також означає, що вам це не подобається. Я вважаю
комедії нудними.
Я вважаю, що фільми жахів лякають, добре, тож
давайте потренуємося з фразою я не
люблю ходити в кіно і вирішимо, що я
просто ненавиджу Дженні, я просто ненавиджу ходити в кіно
кіно добре Олена мені ходити в
кіно нудно
мені ходити в кіно нудно
добре я Дженна я терпіти не можу я терпіти не можу я
терпіти не можу ходити в
кіно весь час так, допоможи мені з
басейн вибачте, у нас є, наче він буде
синім, добре, а у нас є червоний, не подобається
, не подобається,
скажи, що тобі подобається, мл.  Мені подобається добре зустрічатися
Мені подобається дивитися серіали ти мені сказав, що
не можна терпіти мильні опери, хтось
обманює дивитися щось добре
дивитися щось, що ще ти любиш
плавати
Мені подобається добре, то що ти робиш із
відпусткою, приємні жінки, які я їм  я
що це робиш ти читаєш любиш читати
так їсти дивитись плавати як щодо
тебе Аліна ти б хотіла чаю я читаю
читаю добре я буду читати рекламу тут і
давайте з тим, що вам не
подобається
Я не люблю добре сидіти що ще
як їсти що ще нам потрібно дієслово самовдоволений
трави дії бігати грати спати
спати спати це неправда
люди добре, але це лише приклад
добре робити домашнє завдання робити домашнє завдання
робити домашнє завдання що ще
кататися на лижах це  добре
, ти любиш кататися на лижах, Лена, так, так, ти любиш
,
тому у нас є приклади, які тобі
не подобаються, і це рад,
а синій схожий, тому я вказую маркером
на тебе, а ти даєш  e мені речення будь-яке
речення як приклад, тому якщо я
вказую на блакитну Дженну, їсти,
як добре їсти, швидко дайте мені
речення, я жартую, мені подобається це добре, якщо я
вкажу на вас, їм не подобається я не
знаю  сидіти добре молодець готовий так,
давайте робити це як бій дуже швидко
готовий 1 2 3 іду
я люблю читати я не люблю спати я
люблю їсти я не люблю сидіти
я люблю дивитися я люблю плавати
я люблю дивитися я робив добре
домашнє завдання, а про вас я як Гаррі
Поттер, дуже дякую, це було
дуже добре,
тому щоб пам’ятати, вам потрібно працювати
швидко, тому це може допомогти вам добре,
давайте рухатися далі, тому ми збираємося створити
подібний  діалог так,
подібний діалог, ваша черга, тому перш
за все згадайте про
кінотеатр глядачів Хоббіт так, ви збираєтеся
стрибати так
так, давайте згадаємо інформацію про
Хоббіта, ви хочете, щоб я написав на
дошці про Хоббіта 20:00
що хоббіт бореться з драконом, щоб
повернути вкрадену гору. Ні, тож
ви підете до «Хоббіта»,
коли почнеться час так 8:00
вечора.  вечора  є в електронній пошті або
вранці ввечері ввечері добре, так що
це за фільм прив'язаний, коли
пригоди фентезі добре що далі так що
це за фільм про те, хто головний
герой Мартін Фріман, я і мама
мій друг добре, а
який фільм про Хоббіт б'ється
проти дракона, щоб повернути їхню вкрадену
гору, добре, я сподіваюся, що він бореться
проти геїв проти так, проти дракона
і щоб повернути Гору
правильно, так правильно, так що це для вас, щоб ви запам'ятали,
тож давайте мати  погляд у
нас є щось, що висловлює подобається не подобається
запитувати про сюжет сюжету - це історія
про сценарій і питання
про акторську гру, тому хто починає в ньому, але
це тому, що будь-яка користь - це акторський склад будь-який
хороший це також можливий акт присідання
або загартування добре  Говорячи про сюжет,
ви також можете сказати розкажіть мені сюжетну
ну сюжетну лінію О, про що це основний сюжет,
тож давайте подивимося на
діалог,
щоб перша фраза замість
науково-фантастичних фільмів ви могли  n виберіть
свій власний фільм добре, тому я хотів би побачити,
чи змінюєте ви фільм, наприклад, ви
говорите добре, особисто я люблю драми,
і тому я хотів би побачити «Титанік», тому що
драма ви називаєте фільм так, ви змінюєте
це  вибач Алане, але, чесно кажучи,
постійно, і знову ні, це
те, про що ти збираєшся згадувати про
драми, тому ти кажеш, що вибач, Алане, але,
чесно кажучи, Дженна,
я не можу терпіти драм, я віддаю перевагу наступному,
ти зміниш це добре.  один культ,
який ти хочеш перейти до Хоббіта добре,
хм, я не чув про це, що це
про
те, що це про Хоббіт, який бореться з
ким він у Мартіні Фрімені так,
на відміну від нього, lalala, вибачте,
і, на жаль, я не потрапив на 6:30
але з початку я сказав, що
о годині потрібно зустрітися о 20:00  ні, тому ви
перейдете на 7:30 так, добре, давайте спробуємо, так
хто почне, хто такий Алан, добре,
давайте давайте залишимо цей сюжет, щоб ваш
Алан привіт Білл,
чи хочеш ти піти в кіно
завтра ввечері, добре, чому б ні, що йде
добре особисто я  Я знайшовся поза пригодами,
тому я хотів би побачити жах, як ти
думаєш, вибач, Алане, але, чесно кажучи, я
терпіти не можу або я віддаю перевагу пригодницькій
фантастиці, ну є одна під назвою
Хоббіт мм. Я не чув про неї,
що це таке  це про те, що
Хоббіт бореться з драконом, щоб повернути
їхню вкрадену гору, яка
коштує будь-якої користі,
головні ролі Мартін Фріман о, він мені дуже подобається,
я думаю, що цей фільм починається о сьомій
о восьмій, добре, о годині  о восьмій
годині,
тож давайте зустрінемося біля кінотеатру о
6:30, добре, побачимось там, це чудово, щоб
я міг відповісти на твоє запитання, ти любиш
їсти, щоб ти міг з’їсти попкорн О
[Сміх]
давайте розглянемо деякі характеристики, щоб Ед був добре, добре,
а потім Т  Ви можете обговорити, що ми
будемо їсти піцу, суші, так що ваш
домашнім завданням буде створити
подібний діалог, дозвольте мені допомогти вам з
картою розмов, тож коли ви розмовляєте,
це типова розмова між двома
людьми, такими як Алан і Білл, добре,
тому, перш за все, Алан гритс, білл, привіт,
як справи,
потім людина запитує  наступна людина, яка
піде з вами в кіно, чи б ви хотіли
піти, захочете піти в кіно,
щоб запросити людину, як щодо того,
щоб піти в кіно, добре,
людина буде такою людиною, щоб відповісти,
і перш за все  вона чи він погоджуються, що
так, я б хотів, і запитав, що відбувається,
тож які можливі варіанти,
які є фільми, щоб наступний О,
Алан запропонував фільм, як фільм жахів
або догори ногами, або Хоббіт і
Б.  висловити неприязнь, це ніби ні, мені
це не подобається, тож давайте почнемо
переговори, добре, запропонуємо інший фільм,
і тепер B запитає про сюжет,
тож що там, і перша особа
описує сюжет B запитає
про акторів, які  чи є
це важливо  t відповісти так чи ні, це
залежить від мене він подобається мені він не подобається, тоді
B висловиться як фантастичне, тому
ми домовимося про фільм, потім a запропонує
час і місце, і B погоджується, щоб ця
карта розмови могла допомогти вам
діалог і що буде
далі
добре, коли ви створите подібний, що
я зроблю зараз, настав час вікторини добре
запитання готові давайте підемо перше
запитання, вам потрібно вибрати правильну
відповідь, цей
вибачте, але немає  більше квитків
на виступ а добре, я візьму один
B, шкода,
дивись, я більше не хочу так,
шкода, секретний ключ, ні бікіні для
другого пілота Тельця ах, шкода
[Сміх],
що ви думаєте про фільм
е, це була марна трата часу BI не відчуваю,
що це
бачу, я думаю про це, це була
марна трата часу, оскільки червоні зміщення були
швидшими, і останній фільм жахів, який я вважаю,
дійсно нудними,
я знайшов це в  Магазин DVD, я радий, що
вам це подобається.
Давайте подивимося щось інше, ніж C
стажер ангр  y і відповідь подивіться
, є підказка для вас, добре, добре,
дивіться, подивіться, давайте подивимося, тоді,
якщо вам це не подобається, давайте виберемо
інший так, так, так, тому що я
хочу порадувати вас, тому домашнє завдання
для вас, хлопці  створіть власне діалогове вікно
за допомогою карти розмов наступного разу, коли
я перевірю вас
[Музика],
і видно, на жаль, ми повинні
зупинити урок добре дякую дуже дякую
[Музика]
поки що це була ніч, яка напружила мене
було небезпечно їсти як шітаке,
і, мабуть, я читав з розуму, коли ти
робиш це фото було деменцією excel, так
що йди, ти не вали вчених
атакуєш поважаю інші течії, дозволяю,
якщо ти багато робиш з нашим матеріалом канал
crudo новий твій  школярі я можу остудити
скнару, перемігши Росіо Моссад
так, однорічний макрокотедж шоку
можливе рішення - бажання не
лепрекона о так, сподіваюся, я знову полюблю
[Музика]
Papapa
Мені подобається, тому я роблю так мені подобається Мені подобається мені
подобається - так  пухир, який
хтось повинен обожнювати  наше питання місто
все о так, а потім так, так, дай
рядок у моєму, якщо ми esprit my, би
сказав хвилини епідуральна
ти